[Music]
let's take a look at cadet Kelly yeah
it's pretty obvious I'm not the target
demographic for this film but for the
target demographic I think this is a
perfectly serviceable little flake an
artsy little free spirit likes to hang
with her divorce mom and dad but gets a
little surprised when she finds out that
her mom is getting remarried to Gary
Cole playing the role of oh my god I
think he's just called sir do we ever
know his real name
let me IMDB that oh my god he's just
called sir anyway as you probably can
tell from that name he takes the
military very seriously so not only does
Kelly have to move away from her school
of alternative learning you know where
they sit on beanbags and can do
assignments whenever they want and you
know one of those super liberal schools
and suddenly has to go to boot camp
honestly it's not made entirely clear
why I guess because the stepdad is there
maybe she got in trouble a lot mom
doesn't look like it I don't know the
focus is on Kelly trying to adapt with
her drill sergeant Jessica played by Kim
Possible star Kristi Romano she of
course doesn't fit in claiming that her
old school was a lot different and
everybody's too rough why it's almost
like this is military school or
something but for a lot of goof-ups
understandings and misunderstandings
she'll figure out there really is
something to all this strictness and her
mother and stepdad will also figure out
I don't want that have to a changing
world I'm a surface this sounds pretty
generic
yeah good chunk of the time it is but
there are little touches that make it
stand out a little bit more from this
kind of story heard a million times for
example I like that she comes from this
really open school where they do like
arts and crafts and are super gentle
that makes a much better contrast and
understanding of why she doesn't fit in
the family dilemma is also interesting
to the father strict and sometimes says
the wrong things but by no means a bad
guy he like Kelly is trying to
understand what's the best route to take
in terms of this family and it's totally
identifiable I also like how nobody is
100 percent right or 100% wrong Kelly
does get in a lot of trouble and she's
properly punished for it resulting in
emotional scenes that a lot of time kind
of feel genuine when hillary duff cries
it feels like she's really crying and
when the parents will come
used or screwed up you can tell it means
a lot when they did something wrong
there are definitely problems though and
a lot of them center around the Jessica
character Christine Romano is a very
talented actress I just don't think she
was the right pick for this part this is
supposed to be someone tough controlling
and in charge and she just kind of looks
like she's trying to play a role of
someone being tough controlling and in
charge she just kind of seems snooty and
pissed off
not really commanding Authority and I
get it Kelly's supposed to wear her down
and get to her humanity but she just
doesn't feel like a genuinely
intimidating character that needs to be
softened up there's also some strange
issues with Kelly and her hitting on the
same boy and even at the end he doesn't
really choose which one he's gonna go
with and I don't know it's more
uncomfortable than charming and yes by
the way that is Iceman horn boy yeah
like I said I never really got why she's
going to military school I don't know if
I miss something but I feel like that's
kind of a big decision and should
probably be made very clear why this is
happening seeing how it's the whole
focus of the film but again you could
argue that's not really the film's in
depth its intent is trying to show a
girl adapting to this new world and to
its credit making this new world seem
different but also impressive we see
movies like stripes where the goofballs
go to boot camp and all sorts of crazy
things happen and oh isn't that say me
but I like that this film looks like it
legitimately respects the military
there's a lot of impressive marching and
techniques and they look legitimately
disciplined and even cool while doing it
what's up the final number in the
competition I don't know they're
building this up is like a big deal and
they have to work together in order for
this to work and they need passion and
inspiration and they can use ribbons now
and play pop songs and even if that's
true it's edited in such a way that they
play scenes twice or speed it up and
then slow it down and that's really
cheating and it looks lame the scenes
before we're so impressive why did you
have to dumb it down like this no no
maybe they didn't have time to rehearse
it well enough that that looked
incredible but I felt like this was a
cheap way out however I do big time give
credit to the ending without giving too
much away not everything wraps up in a
neat little bow I really like it when a
kid's film shows not everything is 100%
happily ever had
shit happens you have to deal with it
and you know what you still count your
blessings and look on the bright side I
think that's a better message than
always do your best and everything will
always turn out your way so yeah what I
put this on again know what I took it
out first time probably not but for an
adult who had to sit through this I
think it gets across the right messages
sometimes subtle sometimes too
on-the-nose cadet Kelly passes with okay
you